why's women
new motivation
whattcha top ten with believe nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to look
into the accountability mirror silence
the noise and get rid of negativity with
David Goggins and my take on his top ten
rules a success vol 13 joy okay let's
kick it off with rule number one look
into the accountability mirror your
biggest enemy your biggest the most
important conversation you will ever
have in your life is the one you have
with yourself you wake up with it you
walk around with it you go to bed with
it eventually you're going to act on it
whether they good or bad you have to
that's why the whole thing about this
book I have it's about you it is about
you it's strictly about you finding who
you are so many people die live 100
years never know who they are never know
who they are you have to look in that
mirror and know this there's so much
more in here man because I can literally
right now be a 300-pound guy spraying
for cockroaches still to this day if I
did not look in that mirror and say
there has to be more to this this can't
be it
and then willing to go into it dive deep
into it and give all I have to find it
rule number two silence the noise what
do you think is the biggest stumbling
block that most people face with this
kind of journey honestly is they have
the well with me mentality it's too hard
life isn't fair these things in life are
not easy for me you you look to your
left you look to your right and you
start to judge yourself off other people
like if you're a female she's skinny she
doesn't workout us
as I do and everything starts to corrupt
your mind you start to look around too
much other people what they're doing and
that starts to corrupt your own dialogue
we are judging ourselves against too
many people you have to judge yourself
against yourself and that's the one
thing I started learning this is the
race against me and rich role this is
race against David Goggins and David
Goggins alone if once you can silence
all that [ __ ] all the outside
interference and things that are
attracting your mind to everything you
can then start to grow it realizing I'm
stressed out for no reason this is a
whole new race there's no timeline and
this time I'm gonna run it rule number
three get rid of negativity let's say
for instance we have a family I said
we're all a big family here
all three of us all four of us are a big
family and every morning I'm getting up
training for tours at Mile Run and you
see me give at four o'clock in the
morning and all you are sleeping and by
the time I get done running my thirty
you come I come home just getting up how
you gonna feel about yourself a lot of
times in your over achiever and you have
people that's what talk about the
mediocrity thing a lot of our family
members a lot of our friends they're
mediocre there's always those couple of
guys who are uncommon who want to be
better but you make that mediocre feel
like well this your mom your dad whoever
you make him feel horrible I've been
there I'm speaking from experience you
get some my around you may who's trying
to be better and you don't have the
drive that they have it's a constant
reminder of how tough you are you have
to know that that's what it is anybody
in your core is not saying man get after
but I'm so proud of you they have a
problem with themselves because all you
trying to do is achieve more if that's a
problem for somebody you have to look at
them and say man you really have a
problem with yourself huh rule number
four grind yourself to greatness so I
get the VFW war for the for the
Americanism award for military service
and giving back I'm as human as human
can be that's why what you see is what
you get
at that moment when I was giving my
speech and I thank my uncle for being
there and I got to my mom it wasn't just
about her it was I I know what she went
through I know what I went through and
we got knocked down so much I had a
moment in front of all these great
American heroes where I had a chance it
was like so fast it went through me like
like lightening of I can't believe I'm
here I can't believe I'm getting the
award like this that that kid who was in
the fetal position the majority of his
life and so much the fact that my body
and my hip flexors are tight to this day
that even though I was standing erect my
mind was in the fetal position and when
I looked out amongst all those people it
was a sense of pride that I can't even I
can't even explain it's the moments of
three hell weeks it's the moments of in
that room by myself studying for hours
and hours and hours trying to catch up
with all the kids who above me it's just
those moments like the real raw moments
of life that was like boom hit me and
were gone but I was like I did that
overcame this you know it's like this is
power behind the leash and that's the
feeling I was looking for in my life I
found it wasn't money when Fame wasn't
Awards and it was that feeling heavy
right now they feel I'm about to break
down but it's not of like oh my god I'm
upset it's like I worked myself so hard
that I turned a person this up into this
right here not off of reading the book
off a theorists off of going to work on
myself and saying I don't know how to do
this but I know that to get over their
left side
I got a grime myself into a fine powder
and I did it I did it all for sure will
and very few people will know how that
feels very few also if you want to have
more confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below everything I
didn't want to do is what got me to
where I'm at today you can outwork
anybody it's about what you're saying to
yourself but it also comes at work so
whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
rule number five be patient to get up
every day or five days a week whatever
when it's snowing sunny not not shiny
not not comfortable and to go in the gym
and workout when you don't want to go to
gym and it's not fun and we want it very
fast if you don't see results in the
first two days or the first week I'm
done that's the mentality of most people
their struggle is to real
we're not patient we like in the world
where you can google the best
restaurants around me right now no one
is patient and for you to lose weight
for you to stop drink if you where the
hell you're going through it takes a lot
of patience a lot of time and a lot of
pitfalls a lot of plateaus you get
smooth plateaus if you'll know how to
get around that plateau it's not gonna
happen fast mm-hmm yeah everybody wants
the hack yeah everybody wants to have
there is no hack man rule number six
take care of your body well my morning
routine is every day I get up and run
every single day because why I hate that
the most so that is why I share that
feeling yes I think that the most so you
have to do something that sucks every
day because why once you overcome to
suck
oh now you're powerful you've overcome
yourself already so now you're ready to
battle I go to the gym about four times
a week
but my biggest thing I do is my
nighttime routine I stretch out anywhere
from two to four hours every night for
the last five but it used to be a lot
longer than that and I talked about in
my book why I started doing this thing
but I had through my whole life as you
see I was using my fight-or-flight
muscle I was under severe stress as a
child growing up my job whatever a lot
of stress just sitting down right now
Ross using our psoas muscle your hip
flexor muscle and I'll give you a
two-second on that that muscle attaches
to your t12 and about five or six years
ago I got really really sick doctors
give me all kind of hormones take this
take this take this and it's in the book
real good so I'm gonna go deep into it
now but I laid back and I literally said
you know what I'm dying
the doctors can't figure out what's
wrong with me my blood tests were coming
back fine I just said my I can't even
run a block I read from a 205 miles that
came around a block I'm in my bed
sitting there and I started realized I
had these humongous knots all my hip
flexors and back in my head and I said
I'm just done
so I started slowly stretching out I
couldn't do anything over a period of a
couple of years I got off this
medication that medication I was on like
50 I was on several medication I'm on
one and honestly I would I believe no
doctors have said this is what happened
to you I was literally so tight I was
cutting off blood supply in different
places in my organs the more opened up
my body so now I went from running eight
thirty mile on a training run to now
running a 7:15 a seven-minute mile on a
training run at the same heart rate and
it's not because I'm training any
different it's just because my body my
body's opened up it's loud more blood
flow so every night I stretch out and
it's truly nice to be wound so tight
like I couldn't sit in this chair for
this long
I'm like I could get out of here maybe I
go it's totally changed my whole
perspective of life it's changed
everything so stretching out yoga all
those things has put me in a whole
different state of mind it's the
healthiest I've been in my entire life
merely and physically rule number seven
find your fuel
I'm in search for a feeling I'm not in a
search for a trophy I'm not a search for
love not so it's for more followers on
Instagram or social media when I started
this journey years ago and I realized
that I'm gonna be somebody and I'm
searching for a feeling a feeling of
true victory for myself and only myself
the second I shut out the whole world
and realized that one thing that I am in
this world alone I'm fighting this race
by myself yeah I'm all about people I'm
all about team I'm all about that but
I'm really all about right now and in my
life just like you said no one knows the
real truth about me how hard I really go
I don't care if anybody knows I want
anybody to know I'm an introvert I live
an introverted life and I love that
about me it that right there is my fuel
is I know that there's really no one out
there grinding like me and if they are
so be it if I know about you I'll make
sure that my gang that's what the
mentality is all about my whole thing is
a mentality thing like I told you the
last times on the show I view myself as
the weakest person on the planet Earth
my goal in life was to in my mind
believe I'm the hardest man alive and
that's why the whole thing is can't hurt
me that's what it's about it's about
whatever you think you are you have to
make that dream a reality but that's
where the hard part is is making that
dream reality rule number eight find out
who you really are
that's why it was important for me to
finally realize stop being all these
fake people I used to be stop being
afraid
there was no growth until I cut myself
down to nothing to the person I really
was the real human being and once I
found out who I really was
that's when I started growing I was
trying to build on top of a lied up
foundation you can't build a house in
the foundation so
to get down to the actual mineral soil
of who I was naturally you can start
real growth rule number nine
stop being normal so you're gay I got an
email from this lady she says to truly
enjoyed my book but as she read it she
thought I was this crazy self is she
ready she put the book down and started
living a normal life just going back
paying bills going back to work
complaining the bus few days later she
has time to think about the book and it
scared her she thought well maybe this
guy isn't crazy and that's what scared
the most maybe he's here trying so
assuming a potential but we're all
capable of doing a lot of people like to
put titles on other people we're doing
extraordinary things it makes them feel
better about themselves
give him a get on jail free card I'm not
crazy I'm just not like you in sports
there's a thing out there called load
management a lot of us like the load
manage our lives
when you do that you can find yourself
right at normal get off that stay hard
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is strengthen
yourself is there something that you
want to be known for the one thing that
you want to stand out through all of
these accomplishments and be remembered
for honestly I honestly want to be
considered one of the hardest men to
walk the planet earth in the history of
the world and I mean by heart I'm not
talking about the guy who got the most
pull-ups the most sit-ups runs the most
just a person who's able to overcome any
adversity in front of him to figure out
a way hardest isn't about all this
physical man yeah it helped me get to
where I'm at but all I was doing in the
whole process the process wouldn't be
ripped it wouldn't walk around my shirt
off that wasn't it I knew through the
physical challenges through the physical
suffering my mind was getting stronger
I was literally doing that for a reason
I had a weak mind
all the rest is happened to come with it
I was trying to strengthen the mind a
hand
all that all the judgment that's passed
on me perceived and not sometimes you
make it up in your own head you know I I
I just want to be able to handle all of
that
everything physical mental I want to be
perceived as that like the old-school
barbarian Oh school God it's like god
man
nothing can hurt the guy which is why
the book is titled
it can't hurt me I want people to have
that mantra in their life take that with
you
take it everywhere you go in life and if
you believe that and you work towards
that Callos in your mind strengthen
yourself can't hurt me as strong in any
situations like Niles and Buzz they beat
the [ __ ] out of you I'd be the first one
to give up so he can't hurt me and they
were beating the hell out of me but you
say that enough to you
false motivation becomes real motivation
after well now I have a special bonus
skip from David on how to get inside
your soul that I think you can enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to stop being normal number two
what's the negativity that you need to
get rid of and number three what is the
accountability mirror telling you to do
and if you like this video and you are
gonna take action give me a hash tag
believe down the comments as well
successful people this world who still
feel empty inside and they wonder why
they still feel empty so try to make
another million two million three
million let's buy a new car new house
new boat let's buy more everything in
the day is feeling physically empty
inside
for me I would even successful I still
empty so I was trying to hi rainy
securities my doubts always [ __ ] so
I'll try to just up a turn and we jump
this is the turn you're still a turd
it's like a turkey you get a turkey for
Thanksgiving feel know what you're doing
you cook them without going inside or
cleaning it out you gotta clean the
insides out before
start dressing up same thing but life if
you don't get inside your soul inside
your heart and fix it be willing to go
to war with yourself
if you want more David Dawkins check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there it's so easy to be
great nowadays because everybody else is
most people are weak the whole thing
about comfort zones is